um I actually got to I was near Shane
Gillis I was in Austin my friend's a
rapper named Freddy Gibbs he went on
Rogan and I went with him and I was like
I saw Joe Rogan and met him at his place
super cool spot I bet uh later on that
night we go to a comedy show everybody's
there but I go up to Joe Rogan and I'm
like hey man I started eating shrooms
cuz your podcast and so I pulled out
some shrooms and I was like would you
take a micro do with me and he was like
I got to plan that [__] out buddy and I
was like it's okay I'll have I'll have
two so I was off of [__] shrooms and
I also had an edible and I was drinking
dude and I had one of the most fried
yeah bugged out wild tweaked out nights
of my life in Texas it was just that's
the place to go do it though you know
bunch of beautiful landscape just
everything's flat have you ever had like
a terrible trip no actually man I I've
had I've had some moments you know but I
feel like they always led to like real
profound like I've had I've had like
I've had side of it a better man I've
had a couple where I just like just
solved and I was like God this was
perfect this is every it's always taught
me something really good I think the
closest thing I ever had to one that was
weird so uh my best friend SM Jal
Bridges man uh he we we had went for his
21st birthday so his dad like lived in
Vegas and and we we we're going to bring
a bunch of shrooms and we're like [__]
we didn't figure out how we're going to
fly with these can't just fly with out
some mushrooms you know but we were we
were [__] so we decided we decided to
just take a gigantic just eight a
mouthful man and I got an eighth of it a
piece and um oh [__] and when dude dude
it was the worst situation of my life I
mean the flight was great cuz it was
like from from like daytime to night
time East Coast from Atlanta to West
Coast and I saw like the sun setting but
we were also flying spirit so I might
have been helpful you know it might have
been helpful cuz there was nothing to
watch you know so I know so I was just
looking out the window for 5 hours like
like and you're like this there's no
room but getting on the flight like the
flight was absolutely breathtaking you
know and but go like it was Saturday
night at Atlanta Airport the busiest
airport ever and I'm [__] tripping
face on mushrooms going through TSA and
that was like that was the worst thing
that has ever happened to me that was
like I was that was like I don't know
how I'm going to get through it I just
felt like I was like walking with my
backpack like a [__] robot and
everybody was just like I thought I
thought everyone star TSA hammered on
anything is rough just vibrating take
your [__] shoes off you're
like yeah thank God for free cheick
nowadays not that I'm doing mushrooms at
the airport anymore but would do if I
was right now in my life it would be the
prime time pre check would be the time
or or you know when you go to like a
like a private jet or something yeah
exactly right now a prime time to go
through TSA you land in Vegas and you're
just primed up for Vegas as soon as you
yeah man we we we spent like 5 days for
his 21st birthday and you know we all
just young kids and [__] having the
time of our life it was magical Vegas is
fun you g yeah but it's like two or
three days max for me I think I live
five was just [__] ex you guys end up
at the Spearmint Rhino at all no we did
not we that was just a great I went I
went I saved up like $500 and I went and
I just quarter slotted it and I left
with like 600 bucks after 5 days of kind
of eat that's a [__] win so I was
like yeah baby you're up a 100 bucks
after a week yeah I was like that's
pretty good that pretty solid so now I
just stick to the ding-dings baby you
know just gambling is a it can get bad
like yeah I I I I can't get the I can't
get the bug for it man cuz I just like I
don't have the sports gambling you'll
get the bug for yeah I but see I see one
thing I like about sports gambling I was
talking to my buddy about this and I
make like little ass bets like maybe
like $5 on like a six game parlay you
know like if it hits through yeah yeah
you know and it's it's it's not [__]
money but also it like it's like it
makes the games not only more
interesting and usually five bucks for
like a couple days of dopamine Rush it's
like way cheaper than what I'd pay for
dopamine rushes any other time you know
what I mean usually dopamine cost you
like a hundred bucks and you get an hour
with your friend and then you're laying
in bed like [__] godamn it I can't
sleep and then you're just trying to
jerk off until you can pass out and
that's not happening
either it's true some that's why I try
to tell my wife sometimes I'm like honey
sometimes you just got to rub one out to
get to bed it has nothing to do with you
it has to do with me yeah then you're
[__] laying there till 6:00 a.m. like
you [__] liar everybody if they
[__] knew what you you know you
you're just beating yourself up cuz all
that dopamine's gone your bra you're
going beat yourself off yeah beating
yourself up and beating yourself off
that little guy is [__] that guy's
just [__] laying there like come on
man come on man do something for me baby
I got to go to sleep there's nothing
like trying to go to sleep on shrooms
though cuz you close your eyes and
you're like [__] have you ever have you
ever like [__] boned anybody on
mushrooms I I always think about it you
know like or always think like damn
should have tried jerking off that could
have been cool you know and I just never
that's just the last thing on my mind
when I'm when I'm in the middle of a
trip I don't I'm not like let's [__]
go jerk off real quick I just don't
think and and just being alone jerking
on tripping balls is awful I've probably
only jerked off on shrooms like twice
was it tight it wasn't bad
I know if was going to be like sick you
know I
just full screen oh [__] yeah headphones
on VR set Oculus on oh the you know
what's crazy is I haven't tried that but
I have an Oculus oh yeah he's time to
run that baby yo the Oculus porn while
on shrooms take a couple more tops and
see what happens to you oh [__] texes me
and let me know wash your hands first
though you know I'm say you ever have
post hey hey Teddy have you ever had
post nut Clarity yeah all the time man
where you're like you got like 13 tabs
going on the Hub God and you're like you
disgusting dis once you bust you look
down and you're like a [__] God all
these potential [__] jerks you had
like yeah I can't even get to all the
tabs you know I know I I try I try my
best to just be like you know these days
I'm like man it's it's it's it's so
awful for your brain to know that we
just have something new all the time you
know just have something like whatever
we want whatever takes our little button
is like it is so negative thumbnails you
got to find the thumbnail it can't be
good for you it's terrible for you oh
it's horrible especially if you're
trying to be in love with someone you
know it's probably bad so I try to I try
to now I mean now currently I'm single
so it's you know [__] it I can look at
whatever I want you know but I want to
follow I'm I'm at a spot where I'm
longing for companionship and I like you
know and I have a hopeful so I'm trying
to be like better about just jerking off
six times a day what you could do is you
could sleep on your hand right and then
you wake up and
and then you your your arms asleep and
you give yourself a stranger The
Stranger yeah the left-handed Str for me
it's the right-handed stranger that's
what they do in jail they give
themselves strangers that's a good idea
in more than one way in more than one
way